in an office building in North London
they've been watching an entire people
being erased from the map this is ending
after the scorched earth campaign hits
it and the Ranger part of the village as
you can see from the brown is completely
burnt to the ground in one satellite
photo after another the patterns the
same a village before and after its
attacked by the Burmese military and
vigilantes the brown areas the burnt-out
Rohingya homes untouched the blue roofs
of their nan reinga neighbors
photographic evidence says Amnesty
International of crimes demanding
justice this is a widespread and
systematic attack on the Ranger
population it's on the range of
population on the basis of their
ethnicity of their religion its crimes
of murder crimes of rape forcible
transfer of the population they are
international crimes and they do need to
be held to account and at the moment
we're not hearing anything about justice
and accountability across my Amar's
rakion state have been mass rapes
killings and house burnings were ever
there are a hinga villages forcing a
mass exodus unseen since the Rwandan
genocide fleeing to the city of copses
bizarre and neighboring Bangladesh
settlements further south and since
August a twenty-fifth half a million
more fleeing to find shelter in
makeshift camps in total as many as
800,000 may have been forced to flee
leaving only 300,000 behind the full
horror of what is happening to the
Raheen years may only now be emerging
but they've been persecuted for years
and evidence of that has been gathered
and handed in to governments around the
world including Britain's the world's
leaders cannot claim they haven't known
what is going on there the first letter
was sent 16th of April 2014 the British
government has been advised in writing
since 2014 that a genocide is underway
in Miami they are trying to remove throw
hinges they're trying to destroy them as
a group if you remove the Ranger from
Rakhine State using violence terror
murder rape destruction of property that
is a genocide I lacked you were trying
to destroy them as a people
the UN calls it ethnic cleansing but
these experts in international law say
that's given governments including
Britain's an excuse for inaction I think
the government is trying to shirk their
responsibilities they are trying to
avoid the obligations that the genocide
treaty places on them by not calling
this what it is not calling it genocide
if you call it ethnic cleansing it lets
governments off the hook and that is to
the advantage of the Myanmar government
we showed skies report from rakion state
to mark field Foreign Office Minister
for Asia and put those criticisms to him
this appears to be an attempt a
systematic attempt to wipe out an entire
race that's genocide isn't it well
listen genocide is illegal tell that I
don't get all legalistic when I'm going
with you Dominick on this but I think
it's one of the dangers about talking
about genocide again it you know that is
an issue that has to go through to the
International Court of Justice to
determine whether or not the genocide
there is a problem on the ground now
that we have to deal with I you know
it's a little like all the talk about
whether we take away the Nobel Prize in
angling sushi it's a bit of a sideshow
in the scheme of things the most
important thing as we deal with the
problems that we have now but critics
say Britain and other nations can't do
enough until they do recognize this as
genocide from the UN down the world has
seemed reluctant to do more to protect
the Romania's that says one authority on
Mayim art will prove a huge mistake
Western leaders simply do not want to
put too much pressure on the Myanmar
fragile democracy so what they're
essentially seeing is that we're willing
to tolerate an ethnic cleansing and
generals say to protect this very very
fragile democracy just actually a
contradiction in terms
it's pretty flawed logic isn't it it's
extremely flawed logic you know you hear
you have a situation in which a
significant portion of your population
has been ethnically cleansed as the
model is being raped and there and the
rest is essentially saying that you know
this is okay this is the kind of
democracy that we we welcome with most
rohini are now forced out of their
country or killed
Burmese operations against them are
slowing down their mission close to
accomplished
ethnic cleansing or genocide its
perpetrators have so far got away with
it
dominate Waghorn Sky News